une compétition très attendus par ces
passionnés de la chaque année les
filles se prépare durant plusieurs mois
pour ce grand prix
pour beaucoup d'entre elles il faut
jongler entre la passion du vélo et
l'école c'est le cas de catalina qui
sort tout juste d'une épreuve du bac
je suis venu tout de suite mes parents
m'attendais en dehors du lycée
je suis venu titiller je veux chhabiyé
sur le chemin je suis descendu à vélo et
je suis arrivé à la piste il cette année
surtout c'était assez compliqué entre
que j'ai eue les révisions les coups
qu'ils étaient plus intenses
et oui c'est une production importante
pour nous se prépare chaque année faire
de notre mieux le jour j le cyclisme
chez les filles est une discipline qui a
encore du mal à trouver sa place
selon la responsable des féminines du
comité de cyclisme de martinique
il est même souvent discriminées la
barrière principale ce sont les hommes
qui n'acceptent pas de voir les femmes
faire un sport masculin
que ce soit au foot ou autre c'est la
barrière mon mental des hommes ya des
hommes pour les femmes qui font du sport
il ne les reconnaissent pas et on en
trouve dans le monde du cyclisme
là disons qu'ils ne veulent pas sont pas
d'accord pour la pratique du cyclisme le
plus pro féminin quoi qu'il en soit
demain pour la première épreuve entre le
gros morne et le vauclin c'est kélian
julius qui partira avec le maillot rose
une étape de 72 km
[Musique]